notre mission c'est d'essayer de sauver
le plus de vies possibles parfois on ne
peut pas sauver tout le monde mais on ne
renonce pas
new york
washington
la souco vie
d'accord ça suffit ils ont peur que
qu'une c'est pour ça que je suis là
nos activités doivent être contre nous
quelle que soit la forme que cela
prendra je jouais le jeu
suis désolé tony quand je vois qu'une
situation dégénère il faut que
j'intervienne c'est plus fort que moi et
moi j'écrase très bien mon point sur
votre magnifique dentition
je sais que nous ne sommes pas parfaits
et leur meilleure défense 7 records
je me suis trompé sur votre compte le
monde s'est trompé sur votre compte
les bouchers
ce n'est pas à moi d'assurer leur
protection
nous oblige à nous battre données
vous venez de déclarer la guerre
en dégoût dernière avertissement je peux
faire ça toute la journée
bon ça assez duré quant à toi
salut tout le monde
oui